as vladimir putin prepares to invade
ukraine it's more important than ever to
show our enemies around the world that
the west is strong
united and ready to fight for our
position of global leadership
yes it was embarrassing when a bunch of
illiterate goat herders stole all our
military gear and chased us out of
afghanistan last year and yes
it's not a great look
that
neither american political party
reliably trusts the results of our
elections and okay fine it is
unfortunate that we no longer have a
functioning national border and that
violent crime is surging from coast to
coast and that our population is
literally dying through drugs and
suicide and sterility with no end in
sight
but
but
putin should not mistake any of those
problems for western weakness no sir
just look at our next generation of
leaders
i'm talking about the ivy league
where over the weekend a young swimmer
performed dazzling record-breaking
historic feats of athleticism at the
women's swimming and diving
championships
there
a young woman whose birth certificate
reads will thomas
won the 100 yard freestyle
the 200 yard freestyle and the 500 yard
freestyle
setting five individual records and
pushing all the other gals on pens 400
relay team to set a pool record
yes
just one look at will thomas's maidenly
adam's apple shimmering as
she
glided toward the finish line should
send a shiver down vladimir putin's
spine
the way that her
hulking feminine shoulders plowed
through the water easily overtaking the
other young ladies should strike fear in
the heart of russia's leader the very
words our civilization is strong seemed
to sing from thomas's big
square
delicate jawline as he took women's
sports to new heights in the very heart
of the american elite
no
no no western civilization is not
finished
we're just transitioning i'm michael
knowles this the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on friday is from osu 4 m u l 8
r
he says damn i wish john wick were a
trucker in canada right now this is a
good point now that justin trudeau
and the ottawa government are
threatening to kill the truckers puppies
that seems to have really fizzled the
whole trucker protest if only there were
a john wick there we might be able to
defend freedom tradition our way of life
but that doesn't seem to be happening
anywhere it's not happening over in our
own part of the world it's certainly not
happening over in the east over by
ukraine it's not good at all i mean i
really wish that we could clean up our
political house the best i can do is
clean up my own house when i want to do
that i use naturally it's clean when it
comes to cleaning your home you want a
cleaning product that is safe effective
and affordable that is why i recommend
naturally it's clean a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals they're secret powerful
plant-based enzymes nature's solution to
cleaning when i say powerful i'm talking
about hospital-grade enzyme cleaning
power they've got solutions for almost
every need in the house from the kitchen
to the bathroom to the laundry room this
is the greatest cleaning product i have
ever used
i generally don't do all of the cleaning
in the house but i do a little bit
usually after dinner i'll clean my cute
little buddies uh you know
high chair and i'm just telling you i've
used a lot of cleaning products this
one's the best by far my wife absolutely
loves it i'm encouraging my listeners to
start with four of their top products
conveniently packaged together in the
daily wire essentials kit for a limited
time our listeners can receive 15 off
their order just enter promo code
michael at checkout when you visit
naturallyitsclean.com
michael try these incredible products in
your home today shipping is free
everything is made right here in the usa
naturally it's clean get the daily wire
four pack today go to natural lights
cleaning dot com slash michael use code
michael get 15 off do not delay make the
smarter safer choice for your home
cleaning today with naturally it's clean
vladimir putin must be shaking in his
boots don't you think
what why why oh why would vladimir putin
invade ukraine now when we have a west
that has crimes surging everywhere we're
all at each other's throats we can't
tell the difference between men and
women and the president of the united
states doesn't know what day it is
golly can you believe that he would
aggress
can you can you imagine that it's so
shocking
the situation in ukraine is
accelerating rapidly
this is no longer just western media
propaganda
vladimir putin actually is taking
advantage now he gave a very important
speech it's one of the most
profound speeches one of the in terms of
just a pure political lesson it's one of
the the most interesting speeches of
this century
uh
he gave that yesterday he is clearly
preparing to take the country
this gives donald trump a distinction
this gives donald trump the distinction
of being the only president among the
four most recent presidents on whose
watch vladimir putin did not try to
conquer another country
so yet george w bush what happens
vladimir putin invades georgia and bush
actually to his credit repelled it then
you had obama under obama's watch putin
invaded crimea obama did not repel it so
putin just stayed in crimea then you had
trump
and pretty much everything just stayed
the same and putin didn't try to go any
further
now you have biden and what happens
vladimir putin has 150 000 troops on the
border
he gave this speech yesterday to give
the pretext for war in ukraine it looks
like he's going to try to if he's not
going to take down the whole country
he's going to certainly take big swaths
of the country why why is putin doing
this this is a place where the american
media
the american regime certainly the left
and even parts of the right are making a
huge mistake
they're not understanding the enemy when
you want to talk about geopolitics when
you want to talk about politics at all
it is very important to understand your
enemy your enemy's motivations your
enemy's plan your enemy's strategy the
way your enemy views himself
if you don't understand that if you're
if you're just gonna say well he's crazy
he's just a crazy person
then then you are putting yourself at a
huge disadvantage the american left does
this to the american right in many ways
they say oh you you pro-lifers you're
just crazy you don't have any logical
reasons for not wanting to kill a bunch
of babies you're just crazy you're
sexist you're you're racist the reason
that you don't want to let all the
criminals out of jail it's because
you're racist
right and that's why the left does not
understand the right in america at all
that's why
recently the right has taken a great
deal of advantage well the same thing is
true here for russia what is russia
doing in ukraine
it's not as simple as putin is a madman
he's hitler 2.0 he just wants to conquer
everything it's really it's not that
simple it's much more complicated this
is why i can't get into the the western
rhetoric of we must defend our great
nato ally ukraine ukraine's not in nato
or it's not a member country of nato
first of all since when has ukraine been
our great ally i don't i'm not i
couldn't tell you
since since when does freedom in the
west hinge on ukraine um never ukraine
is one of the most conquered countries
in the history of the world it's been an
independent nation sort of for about
five minutes so i'm not saying that we
should let putin roll the tanks in but
on the other side of that no i don't
think freedom and the western way of
life hinges on the fate of ukraine if it
did we would have lost freedom here a
long long time ago what is this about
well in no small part
it's about two things one is aggressive
one is defensive vladimir putin wants to
recreate something akin to historical
russia whether you call that the soviet
union whether you call that the tsarist
russian empire whatever he wants russia
to be bigger and more powerful than it
is today he vladimir putin famously said
that the dissolution of the soviet union
in the late 1980s and early 1990s was
the greatest geopolitical tragedy
catastrophe of the 20th century so he
wants to make russia bigger and more
powerful sure there's a defensive part
here too though which is that vladimir
putin doesn't want the west going all
the way up to his borders vladimir putin
specifically doesn't want nato to expand
eastward into the traditional russian
sphere of influence and
maybe we in the west want nato to expand
and get bigger and bigger and bigger but
there were plenty of very strong
anti-communist anti-russia voices who
said for decades that this is a really
bad idea i've got i've got an article
here from the new york times this is
from 1997.
it's called a fateful error this is
written by george kennan for those of
you who remember your eighth or ninth
grade history class george cannon wrote
the x telegram the long telegram in
which he
called out the soviet union warned of
the threats of the soviet union he's the
author of the strategy of containment
the main strategy of the cold war
and
george cannon had this to say about what
happens to nato after
the
dissolution of the soviet union the view
is that expanding nato would be the most
fateful error of american policy in the
entire post-cold war era such a decision
may be expected to inflame the
nationalistic anti-western and
militaristic tendencies in russian
opinion to have an adverse effect on the
development of russian democracy to
restore the atmosphere of the cold war
to east-west relations and to impel
russian foreign policy in directions
decidedly not to our liking and last but
not least it might make it much more
difficult if not impossible to secure
the russian dumas ratification of the
start-2 agreement and to achieve further
reductions of nuclear weaponry
he's saying if you expand nato
some some hawks in america think that
they're going to put the west in a much
better position vis-a-vis russia
actually it will have the opposite
effect actually
russia is going to view that as a major
aggression and they're going to get much
more militaristic in response that's
exactly what happened so why why would
why would this all be happening now why
would russia
expect okay sure george cannon and some
other
pat moynihan lots of other strong voices
on the cold war they were saying don't
expand nato but why should russia expect
that that's going to be the national
policy well der spiegel the german
newspaper just dug this up der spiegel
just dug up a document from 1991 in
which the west promised russia that they
would not expand nato eastward
so this was
if not official policy
this was the understanding at the
collapse of the soviet union
all of which is to say
the complication here
the situation here rather is much more
complicated than anybody is really
giving it credit for certainly putin
who's just making his case for war and
even the west and not every not every
single historical event is hitler
invading czechoslovakia not every single
world leader that we don't like is adolf
hitler not every single
epoch that we can live through is 1930s
or 1940s germany okay and there are
complications here you think about the
cuban missile crisis part of the reason
we got a cuban missile crisis is because
the united states botched their policy
vis-a-vis the soviet union in cuba and
in turkey putting missiles there it's
much much more complicated so for those
who do want to preserve the peace it's
going to take a lot more than just bang
bang bang putin bad nato good expand
expand expand you're going to have to
recognize some of the legitimate
questions that our enemies have and try
to answer those with with incentives
rather than merely saying
rah-rah let's go to war in ukraine
now when you want complicated
views of
all sorts of questions i would strongly
recommend you tune into the jordan
harbinger show do you want a new podcast
to look forward to each week one that's
entertaining informative and packed with
actionable content well it's time you
check out the jordan harbinger show a
top shelf podcast named best of apple in
2018. jordan dives into the minds of
fascinating people from athletes to
authors to scientists to mobsters
to spies oh my
harbinger has an undeniable talent for
getting his guests to share
never-before-heard stories
and
thought-provoking insights without fail
he pulls out tactical bits of wisdom in
each episode all with the intent to make
you a more informed critical thinker to
better operate in today's world he's got
a great segment called feedback friday
where jordan covers advice on everything
from psycho family situations to
relationships to networking you cannot
go wrong
by adding the jordan harbinger show to
your rotation it's super interesting
there's never a dull show search for the
jordan harbinger show that's h-a-r-b as
in boy i-n as in nancy g-e-r as in
really go check it out right now on
apple podcast spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts
franklin graham the son of the
evangelical preacher billy graham
got into a lot of trouble he got into a
lot of trouble over this putin-russia
issue
for one tweet he said pray for president
putin today this may sound like a
strange request but we need to pray that
god would work in his heart so that war
could be avoided at all cost may god
give wisdom to the leaders involved in
these talks and negotiations as well as
those
advising them
and what do you think happened it was
the same old thing
same old thing we've heard from the left
for five years now he the right wing in
america they're
russia files they're they're putin
stooges can you believe this christian
preacher is telling his congregation to
pray for their enemies where would he
get this crazy idea he probably got it
out of a kgb handbook or he got it out
of the holy gospel right that's where
these people
these people criticizing franklin graham
and american conservatives and
christians generally
are demonstrating
that they do not know
the first thing even the most basic
thing about
christianity
one of the most basic aspects of
christianity is that we pray for our
enemies we pray for those who persecute
us
this is we get this from the mouth of
christ himself
but our our critics
our
opponents our enemies even they don't
they don't get it i guess this is the
theme that i'm seeing when i look at the
ivy league and that hulking dude setting
all these new women's records and i look
at the situation in ukraine right now
and i look at domestic politics in the
united states and the battle between the
left and the right my main takeaway is
man when did we get this dumb
i don't mean it as a perennial throw
your hands in the air these politicians
are so stupid i mean it in a really
technical measurable way we know much
less today than we knew 50 60 years ago
we i know that we all have
advanced degrees from all different
colleges and we've all got 200 000 worth
of student loans so on paper it seems
like we're much better educated we're
not we don't know anything we are much
much more ignorant
much stupider today than past
generations we don't even know that men
and women are different we don't know
that and if you do have an inkling that
that is the case you're not allowed to
say it that's official policy certainly
from our cultural ministers in some
cases from the government
we don't know anything we have no idea
what russia's relationship to ukraine is
we have no idea what christianity means
i'm saying we broadly as america and
frankly even as the west we have no idea
the foundation on which we've built our
civilization
we just we just know a lot less and this
puts us in a really bad position okay
ignorance is a big political liability
when i read that putin speech i thought
man this is a statesman i'm not saying
he's a good statesman i'm not saying
he's a great guy he's probably a no good
dirty rotten kgb fellow he's done some
good things in russia by the way he's
supported christians in russia more than
you can say frankly for the west he has
helped his country he has secured his
borders he has reversed the decline in
birth rates he's actually done some good
things for the russian people
he still hates the west there's no
question about that so i'm not saying
he's a good guy
but i'm saying he's a very effective
statesman he's a competent statesman
he's not ignorant
like our statesman
he's not even all that haughty like our
statesman he's very calculating he's
very measured there's a reason why
vladimir putin did not go and invade any
other countries when trump was president
it's because he didn't know what trump
would do and he had an inkling that
trump
especially because
trump had cultivated this unpredictable
kind of foreign policy vladimir putin
said you know i don't think maybe i'm
not going to do that
with obama he knew that obama was going
to let him take the countries obama told
him obama told him he was caught on a
hot mic speaking to vladimir putin's
number two dmitry medvedev he was caught
on an open mic at a public conference in
which he said listen i'm gonna have a
little bit more flexibility after after
my next
2012 is my last election i'm gonna have
a little more flexibility after that and
and dimitri medvedev like a cartoon
villain at boris and natasha out of
rocky and bullwinkle he says duh i will
transmit this information to vladimir
and what happens putin invades ukraine
and there's no no problem from the obama
administration then nothing from trump
then we get to biden
and it happens again putin is a very
shrewd guy he knows his history this
this speech that he gave giving the
pretext for war was just a rundown of
russian history from the bolshevik
revolution
to the present i'm not sure it was the
fairest telling of it but his critics
can't point out any of the flaws because
they don't know a damn thing
ignorance is a major political liability
and ignorance is the
theme of the day here in the west you
want to talk about ignorance oh my gosh
this is so embarrassing there's a
french communist
presidential candidate he's not doing
very well in the polls he's got
something like four percent of the votes
so he's not going to become the
president of france but still he's a
presidential candidate in france fabian
gusel
who is campaigning on a platform of
abolishing homework
yes
yes mr russell says comrade russell says
if i become president of the republic
all homework will be done at school and
not at home on the eve of school
holidays i believe that i am not alone
in thinking this would be a good thing
you will be free
the candidate says
you will be able to play sports you will
be able to go to the theater you can go
see your friends
you can see your parents oh this will
you will be free when i get rid of your
homework yeah
it seems radical it seems crazy y'all
leave it to the french leave it on a
communist french to say this this is
exactly what nancy pelosi said about
obamacare
10 years ago more than 10 years ago now
remember she said with the problem with
health care right now is you need to
have a job
but when we decouple health care from
working then you don't need to have a
job then you're then you're free then
you're free to go become a poet you're
free to be a painter you don't need to
worry about your health care you can
just pursue all those things
it's the exact same thing here is you
can go play with your friends
okay i i've got news for nancy pelosi
and this french communist
politician
most people are not poets
most poetry is really really bad most
paintings are not good
during covet i took up painting i enjoy
it's a fun little hobby i took it up in
my little free time
i'm not a good painter i'm not i wish i
were but i'm not
most peop most people are
most people
should be working actually all of us
should be working we are made to be
productive okay
when we're not we atrophy and we go
crazy but this is the freedom that the
left is promising you sometimes the
american right simplifies things too
much
we say that the difference between the
way the left talks about freedom and the
way the right talks about freedom is
that the right talks about freedom from
things freedom from coercion freedom
from tyranny freedom from this from that
and the left talks about positive
freedoms they talk about freedom two
health care freedom two obama phones
freedom two crack pipes if you're in the
biden administration right and that's
the big difference but no the left talks
about negative freedoms too
the left says you've got to be free from
work
you've got to be free from
having to hold down a job you've got to
be free from your homework as they say
now in france
you've got to be free from all of these
things and then you can truly be free
but that's not the way it works
this it gets down to this fundamental
misunderstanding of freedom that we've
been talking about on this show since i
came out with my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which became a number one national
bestseller because of all of you buying
it which i appreciate
the
the the issue here is that the left
thinks that freedom
means just doing whatever you want
whenever you want to do it the left
thinks that freedom is kids getting to
go play xbox when they get home instead
of having to cultivate their minds and
be
productive that's not freedom
the crack pipes from the biden
administration proved this a couple
weeks ago
sitting around smoking crack sitting
around just indulging your own appetites
indulging your basis appetites and not
cultivating your higher more rational
will that's not freedom
freedom is noble freedom requires duty
freedom requires a correspondence with
reality when a dude pretends that he's a
woman and beats all the chicks on the
penn swim team in the entire ivy league
that's not freedom that's delusion
that's the opposite of that's slavery to
fantasy
freedom is when we accept reality we
live in accordance with reality and we
flourish by cultivating the virtues we
used to know that this isn't some
radical point of view everyone agreed on
this until about 50 years ago and then
our culture got really really stupid
leftist radicals took over the
institutions of power they specifically
went after education and they hollowed
it out they hollowed out educate the
education that you are getting today
whether you're talking about elementary
school high school
university certainly the education is
not comparable to what people got 50 60
years ago
you don't know latin you don't know
greek you don't know a damn thing about
philosophy we don't even treat
philosophy like it's real anymore like
it's the best way of living like it's
something that can tell you that what's
true and false and good and bad we just
treat it as some weird historical fact
oh isn't it this is what the greeks
thought about morality who care no one
cares what the greeks thought about
morality i want to know what's true but
instead of that instead of being given a
true rigorous philosophical liberal
education you're being taught that white
people are evil because of the color of
their skin and that men are actually
women and we're dumb and it's weakening
us and it's no surprise that our enemies
are taking advantage it's enough to get
your blood flowing at you really really
tense when you when you want to just
relax a little bit get a nice little
good night's rest i strongly recommend
you go check out helix helix has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way that you sleep
they've got soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses that are great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains even
a helix plus mattress for plus sized
sleepers if you're looking for a
mattress you take the quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to and the
mattress comes right to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again they've got
a 10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk free they will
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix has financing
options flexible payment plans so a
great night's sleep is never far away i
really really love my helix mattress
it's absolutely terrific i can't wait to
get my little children their helix
mattresses when they move out of the
crib just go to helixsleep.com knowles
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at helix sleep
dot com slash knowles that's helix sleep
dot com slash knowles for up to 200 off
and two free pillows go check out helix
today also
america is under attack
the threat is coming from within
that's why we are exposing just who is
destroying american institutions and why
there are a lot of answers to this
question one of them in particular will
be shown on this daily wire series the
enemy within it began streaming
exclusively at the daily wire last week
and features a claimed journalist and
expert in national threats lee smith as
he uncovers a political coup
orchestrated by america's ruling elites
to generate their own wealth and power
at the expense of the american people's
safety and freedom check out the trailer
what if everything we think we know
about our leaders
our society and our relations with the
rest of the world is wrong
america is facing two major challenges
one is the chinese communist party
however the most significant threat
comes from within you're trying to
obscure responsibility for four million
people dying around the world senator
paul you do not know what you are
talking about
we've already seen evidence of how the
elites want to run the united states
they're modeling themselves after
chinese autocracy for over a decade the
people's republic of china
has stood publicly accused of acts of
cruelty
and wickedness
that matched the cruelty and wickedness
of many evil torturers and executioners
dianne feinstein
had a chinese spy as her driver for 20
years we're not talking about
one person infiltrating senior levels at
the cia or the white house we're talking
about an entire elite class
throughout the political corporate
academic cultural and media
establishment my name is lee smith i've
been a journalist for more than 30 years
this is the most astonishing espionage
and infiltration operation in history
what you're going to see in this series
will shock you
this
is the enemy within
the enemy within is streaming now
exclusively at the daily wire so if
you're not a member now is the time to
change that head on over to
dailywire.com subscribe to join us today
also the daily wire has started
publishing our own publishing wing we've
started publishing our own publishing
can you imagine that it's called dw
books we're proud to be publishing two
books that are actively fighting the
left's monopoly on storytelling the
first is 12 seconds in the dark by
sergeant mattingly the book is the true
story of what really happened the night
of the brianna taylor shooting and the
second is fiery but mostly peaceful by
julio rosas who pulls back the curtain
and sets the record straight on blm
riots that broke out across the country
in 2020. rosas who was reporting from
the ground gives his first hand
experience at the riots i cannot wait
for you to hear their stories both are
available for pre-order right now on
amazon or anywhere you buy books online
we'll be right back with a lot more
speaking of our ruling class speaking of
espionage
speaking of corruptions at the highest
levels of power in our society
jeffrey epstein's pimp jean luke runel
got suicided over the weekend yes he did
he got suicided real real good he
couldn't have gotten suicided any better
if he had dirt on the clintons oh wait
he did have dirt on the clintons
i'm not saying
i'm not saying
the clinton's had anything to do with it
i am told there were pant there was a
suspicious looking man in a pant suit
walking around the jail cell where bruno
is being held but i don't know who knows
who knows actually we don't know who was
around the jail cell because there were
no cameras whoopsie daisy uh jean-luc
brunel who was he was this modeling
agent who really just effectively acted
as a pimp shuttling girls to jeffrey
epstein he would one time he sent
jeffrey epstein three 12 year old girls
from france because they were poor the
families needed the money and then
apparently the girls were the
entertainment for one of epstein's
parties
this guy was held in a jail cell
because of accusations of rape because
of all these sorts of issues and he had
allegedly attempted suicide multiple
times
okay so he there was a precedent here
for maybe he's going to eventually kill
himself
but for some reason
he wasn't on suicide watch that's weird
and they had you know guards walking by
doing checks making sure he was okay but
whoopsie daisy i guess
i guess the guards just weren't there
when he killed himself
and for whatever reason there weren't
any cameras outside the cell and
well all shucks
there goes that
epstein
committed suicide allegedly jean-luc
brunel committed suicide allegedly
elaine maxwell prosecuted and as part of
the prosecution agreement they're never
going to open up that black book
to give us all the details
on all the very powerful global
specifically western leaders
who were involved in jeffrey epstein's
organization
where did epstein get all his money we
have no idea
did epstein have ties to foreign
intelligence certainly seems like he did
gelane maxwell's father robert maxwell
was a well-known
intelligence operative
for at least one or two countries maybe
maybe more than that maybe
three countries even
so the whole thing is a little weird was
there state backing in the epstein
operation
what to we we know that when epstein was
was being prosecuted the first time
the u.s attorney at the time was told
by this was alex acosta right who was
then up for labor secretary under trump
he was told
no
watch out about this guy he belongs to
intelligence it's a cost his own word so
that's kind of weird
and then whoopsie daisy
the main kingpin behind this suicided
the pimp funneling the girls suicided
elaine maxwell i guess she's alive
but doesn't look like she's going to be
saying very much of anything
nobody believes this
does
nobody believes
that jean-luc brunel
and jeffrey epstein just so happened to
accidentally be allowed to commit
suicide and whoops the cameras broke and
whoops the guards weren't there and
oopsie-daisy they weren't on suicide
watch and oh well okay moving on no one
believes this
okay
we have very little faith left in our
institutions in the west
because those institutions have really
been hollowed out
in particular over the last 50 years but
we especially don't have any faith in
our intelligence agencies this is why by
the way when our intelligence apparatus
is trying to sell us a war with russia
over ukraine this is why people don't
want to do it
i think this is a major reason why we
are not eager to go defend the sacred
oligarchy of the ukrainians
in the name of freedom or whatever is
because we don't trust the intelligence
agencies we don't trust the state
department we don't trust the deep state
because the deep state does a lot of
shady stuff like this okay they're
involved with people like epstein
according to u.s attorneys in america
and
we don't get the full story and when we
do get the story about what the ic is up
to it seems to be pretty bad stuff like
trying to like spying on donald trump as
a candidate
spying trying to undermine his
presidency based on complete nonsense
colluding with the democrats colluding
with russia actually ironically so we
don't believe them
okay you want i'll give you an example
closer to home on this the cdc right now
has a lot of data on kovit of course
they've been collecting data constantly
for the past two years more than two
years
but they're not releasing all of that
data they're only publishing some of the
data they're cherry picking what data
they want to publish the new york times
is reporting this
according to the new york times the cdc
has been leaving out important data
about the effectiveness of boosters in
adults under the age of 65.
they're only recently beginning to
provide certain other data including
wastewater data why
well in in particular this according to
the times
the cdc published the first significant
data on the effectiveness of boosters in
adults younger than 65 two weeks ago and
it left out the data for 18 to 49 year
olds the group least likely to benefit
from extra shots because the first two
doses already left them well protected
or because the additional shots don't
matter and the younger people are are
much less likely to face serious
complications from the covid
why are they leaving this it doesn't
take a genius you don't need you don't
need a whole lot of brain cells to rub
together to know why they're leaving
they're leaving this out because it
doesn't work for their narrative
kristen nordland who's a spokesman for
the cdc
said the agency has been slow to release
these data quote because basically at
the end of the day it's not yet ready
for prime time
she said the agency's priority when
gathering any data is to ensure that
it's accurate and actionable and they
don't want
the information to be misinterpreted
meaning they don't want the information
to undercut their narrative
information is power that is always true
but it is especially true today because
we live in the information age
since the dawn of modern computing
certainly since the dawn of the internet
information data is power
this is why the federal government
collects all the data on all of us not
just on foreign powers but on all of us
they've got it all to entrench their
power this is why
private businesses are just trying to
constantly scoop up data this is why you
have so many free services apparently
free services right now on the internet
they're not really free you're paying
with your data because data are power
information is power ignorance is
weakness and that this is bad news for
us
this is really bad news for us because
even when we possess data we don't
really know what to do with them in the
west anymore i you know on this show
first you know i hate to say i told you
so but second you know that for a long
time i have said that conservatives
should be wary of statistics you know
the left loves to talk about statistics
they just rattle off their statistics
all day long they say no we look we can
cite the statistics if they help our
argument but the statistics are kind of
silly everyone's got their own
statistics there are lies damned lies
and statistics statistics are
a
the means of
power of maintaining power for the
modern administrative state okay that's
how it works
the the whole point of statistics is
they were developed in the 19th century
specifically at german universities the
word statistic refers to statist right
refers to state power and it was to
power these modern
bureaucracies that then were imported to
america specifically during the
presidency of woodrow wilson they really
get built during franklin roosevelt now
that's how we operate so it's the the
statistics those data though that's the
way that that the
state operates and maintains its power
and when the the bad data come in that
don't support their narrative what do
they do they ignore them and they don't
publish them and they only use the data
that are helpful to them to maintain
their
power think about what vladimir putin
did
he didn't do this in the modern
statistical technocratic you know a bean
counting way but when he was giving that
speech about why he wants to invade
ukraine
the speech was basically just a history
lesson the speech was just this happened
then this happened then this happened it
was just information historical
information to build his case as to why
he's got to invade and it was very
effective particularly because his
opponents have no way to counter even
even the sort of bogus claims that he
made
they don't really have to count they
don't have a lot to counter it because
we in the west don't know much about
history or anything else anymore because
we're spending all of our time in school
learning about diversity equity
inclusion a bunch of other nonsense
it's worked this thing has worked okay
the the the way that the
state is maintaining power right now by
just inundating us with data but only
specific data only
to defend a specific narrative it has
worked look no further than joy behar
joy behar is one of the more eccentric
cackling hens on the view joy behar very
liberal woman
and she has said now look even as the
public health authorities are beginning
to let up on the mask mandates
i still want to wear mine because i'm
just i'm just nervous i'm just afraid
i listen to the little voice in my head
that doesn't really follow 100 what they
tell me because they keep changing it
yep right so like very short time ago
they were saying put the n95 masks on
and make and now they
make sure it's uh and now they're saying
you don't have to wear them anymore yeah
so i if i go on the subway if i go in a
bus if i go into the theater if i go
into um where else would i go crowded
spot a crowded place i would wear a mask
and i might do that indefinitely
because why do i need a flu or a cold
evening
and so i'm listening to myself right now
i sort of lit i mean i don't think it's
100 safe yet
i don't think it's 100 safe yet now what
people are going to point out is that
about three seconds after joy behar made
these comments joy behar was
photographed at a restaurant not wearing
a mask
and according to some reports she wasn't
even wearing the mask when she walked
into the restaurant because you know
from the hostess stand to the table
that's when you can catch kovid but then
at the table you can't catch covet and
so people are pointing to this and
they're saying joy behar are you
hypocrite you don't need to get pictures
of the restaurant
just look at pictures of the view all
these women are sitting together and
they're not wearing masks
you don't need to go
oh wow we caught you not right no we're
watching you now we're a mask on
television you're all sitting next to
each other it is a relatively crowded
place right you have five women who
don't live together who
interact with lots and lots of people
all the time or in very close space and
you're not wearing a mess so what is it
are you a hypocrite
maybe
but i'm not convinced it's even
hypocrisy i have
friends and family members like joy
behar
seriously who are
their
new yorkers first of all
they are very liberal
they they are a little bit neurotic
and they go along with what the
government tells them to do
and
they're
did i mention they're neurotic yeah
they're a little bit neurotic and so
even when the government says you can
loosen up a little bit they still
they're very nervous about their health
now of course it doesn't make any sense
that
okay you're gonna you're gonna wear the
mask that we're already told is by
lyanna when on cnn is nothing more than
a facial decoration you're gonna wear
that when you're on a subway platform
but not when you're in a restaurant and
that's gonna stop or not when you're on
a tv set for that matter and that's
going to stop you from getting covered
we know that that's
not rational but these people are not
behaving in a rational way
okay we are assuming
that these are rational
actors here and that is not always the
case
the effect of the
government
constantly changing its story on kovid
don't wear the masks do wear the masks
don't wear the masks the vaccines are
not going to come out for a year and a
half actually the vaccines are going to
come out in three months the vaccines
are 100 safe and effective there are no
side effects and it's going to stop you
from contracting or transmitting
coronavirus actually whoopsy daisy that
isn't true none of that's true but it's
still you that's why you need to get the
fourth and the fifth shot but you should
still get the first shot if you haven't
gotten the first shot but because it's
so effective but it's not quite
effective and blah blah blah and your
head is spinning by the end of it and
that's kind of the point this is
you want to talk about brilliant
politicians
forget about vladimir putin for a second
look at dr fauci dr fauci is such an
adept politician in no small part
because you can never prove him wrong
and you can never prove him wrong
because he's held both sides of every
single issue
he's helped both sides
just during covid
he's held both sides of
the masks pro mask anti-mask lockdowns
lockdowns are terrible unimaginable
lockdowns are actually great we need
more lockdowns the vaccines the
continued mitigation measures the on and
on and on and on and on
so you can't prove them wrong this can't
exactly prove him right either but you
can't prove him wrong he's always got
that
that way out it's irrational and so
you've got people who just say i don't
know i don't i just i'm just afraid
that's what i give joy behar credit
she's saying i'm just afraid i'm just
afraid and a little neurotic
and powerless
i guess that's probably true you want to
talk about life and death real issues of
life and death
horrible story story over the weekend a
38 year old mother of four was driving
uber to make some extra money
and
a man gets in her she was 38 years old
you can tell by the word was that this
story is not going to turn out very well
a 22 year old guy gets in calvin crew
and he puts a gun to the back of her
head and he says hey
uh
give me your money
she says no please i don't have this
money i don't have this please put the
gun down no no no she goes please i have
a family got four kids he says no no no
no eventually the camera goes out he
shoots her
this guy calvin crew
even though he's only 22 years old he's
a career criminal he's got a rap sheet a
mile long
he's been in and out of the system since
he was a young teenager
he's got an active criminal case right
now involving a firearm
why was this animal allowed to prowl the
streets
why
because of criminal justice reform of
course
we hear criminal justice reform mostly
from the libs but sometimes some
conservatives embrace it too frankly i
mean trump pushed this kind of stuff to
some degree
and we hear oh this is good this is
going to let
you know people who are getting life
sentences for for smoking one puff of a
joint one time this is that's it's gonna
these more frivolous prosecutions
that's not how it works criminal justice
reform in practice is letting these
monsters these animals out on the street
to run roughshod to terrorize innocent
people to destroy law and order and we
can't do it we think that justice in
america today is letting all the
criminals out of the prisons abolishing
prisons as some very prominent democrats
elected democrats have been talking
about is it any wonder
is it any wonder
that our enemies are taking advantage
we got we've got more hits the hits just
keep on coming out of our the criminal
justice reform
movement
four people were stabbed on a new york
city subway
platform or on a new york city subway
train
on saturday within 18 hours within 18
hours
uh among you know new york's not a very
big city
four people stabbed within 18 hours
this as mayor eric adams is going to get
tougher on crime yeah okay
what happened three suspects stabbed a
46 year old homeless man seven times
after attempting to rob him
on the three train at livonia and
vanciclen avenue in brooklyn a man
punched a 20 year old woman in the back
and then when she objected to getting
punched in the back
he slashed her three times in the
stomach two teens uh slashed a 24 year
old man standing in the mezzanine
because he i guess the robbery didn't go
right he didn't just immediately give
them everything they wanted
and a 31 year old man
was standing near a man and a woman on a
train while the woman was smoking
and apparently this started in an
argument and the man from the couple
stabbed the guy
criminal justice reform right
that isn't that great we need to let
these people out of prison we the our
problem you know what our problem is in
america
over incarceration that's what i say
how can you believe you have to be
so miseducated you have to be so
completely deluded you've got to be so
high
not on the haitian oregano but on on
ideology
that you believe
that a man is
really a woman
that you believe
that
there's white supremacy go just wait for
the white supremacy we got a great white
supremacy story coming up white
supremacy running rough shot over
america
and you believe that our biggest problem
in the criminal justice system
is over incarceration we have a severe
under incarceration problem
we don't
deal
with crime and justice anymore
we have a lot of problems and it's not
even just the basic political problems
all the border doesn't work oh we've got
this economic issue oh we've no it's
it's a philosophical problem we don't
know what justice is we think that
justice is letting criminals out of
prison
is it any wonder
that our enemies are aggressing i
promise you i'd get to the white
supremacy story we got another big white
supremacy example here ton of white
supremacy going on
last week the sacramento bee reported
that the sacramento city unified school
district
was investigating racist graffiti that
was written over a water fountain at ck
mcclatchy high school
and the graffiti was apparently a
throwback to segregation you know it's a
colored water fountain here and white's
only water fountain here isn't that
terrible is white supremacy's klansmen
running running loose in
california
[Music]
the superintendent without investigating
a single
aspect of this story
immediately gave a statement he said i
am both angry and heart sick that racist
graffiti was discovered on the ck
mcclatchy campus today we take this
incident very seriously
racism and racist language will not be
tolerated in our schools one father a
black father in the district said
there's something about our culture in
the sacramento city school district that
has to be addressed the inequities the
performance of black kids the racism it
must stop right the the implication here
this is all white supremacy white
anti-black racism
only problem for the narrative is there
were video cameras you know
you know where this is going
you knew where this was going
before i even gave you the details of
the story just you knew right from the
headline
what happened
a black student did the graffiti
it was a hoax
it's not how did how did i know that
this was a hoax the minute i saw the
headline the way i knew this was a hoax
is that white supremacy is an illusion
it's not real
lump it away with the easter bunny and
the tooth fairy don't forget about that
fruit okay it's not
it you would have to be so deluded that
you believe that over-incarceration is
around do you believe that men are women
that you you would have to be so
steeped
from i don't know kindergarten to 12th
grade i'm sorry from preschool to
the end of college i'm sorry until the
end of graduate school till that you
would have to be so steeped in this
leftist ideology as america is
that your grasp on reality
would have to be tenuous if
existent at all
to believe that the ku klux klan is
running america that the ku klux klan is
running california give me a break
but this is what a lot of people
believe
there was some years ago there was a
russian dissident
who
pointed out yes it looks like america's
winning the cold war but the soviets are
going to win it in the end
and the reason the soviets are going to
win it in the end is because they have
exported their ideology
and that ideology
is going to poison america what was his
name yuri
bren something with a bee there's a very
famous clip of this perhaps we'll try to
play it on the show
and he said
it takes about
two generations maybe three generations
to hollow out a country to hollow out a
country's confidence sense of self logic
reasoning
traditions
operating principles
and so sure the west thinks it's
triumphant
as it's winning the cold war just wait
just wait
that's what we're seeing right now
we're seeing right now
the culmination of decade after decade
of hollowing out of america
not just our our freedom you know sure
our freedom that's kind of a symptom of
that
but our conviction
our national unity
our sense that we're really a nation at
all like a nation that has borders that
has a reason to exist all we talk about
now is how awful it is that america
exists in the first place we should
never have come those poor indians
those poor the poor other settlers that
everyone has a right to a country except
for america
oh it's terrible this is native land
this is we don't deserve this we're
colonizers we're this our past was
terrible we need to apologize for
everything we need to
abolish our nationhood and most
importantly
our
our bare
knowledge of really basic things
philosophical things historical facts
we're in it and by the way we're so
proud of ourselves the whole time we're
saying we're the smartest generation
ever we know more we're so bad we're
wonderfully educated we're so brilliant
we're so enlightened we're so bright we
are not we are
living every day more and more so in the
darkness of ignorance
and our enemies around the world are not
okay they some of them have not fallen
for the same poisons that we have
okay
that is playing out in real time in
ukraine and so sure we can send some
troops we can try to defend ukraine the
problem runs much much deeper than that
take a lesson from putin take a lesson
from your enemies
before it's too late i'm michael knowles
this the michael knowles show see
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire